Hey guys,
so pilot season continues here at wise
crack,
so this one is special to us for a
couple of reasons.
First of all,
this is the first time we're going to be
talking about real world events rather
than focusing on media.
Secondly,
we're bringing the vision of one of my
favorite artists to life is the girl
went to college with,
her name is Tyler Rice and we're super
excited to have her aesthetic be part of
the wise crack family,
but also I wanted to introduce the voice
of this pilot,
Jacob,
who is my co founder who created
wisecrack with me about four years ago.
Hey guys,
we're really pumped to get this out to
you guys,
so let us know what you think in the
comments and make sure you let Larry
know to see you guys later.
Enjoy the show.
Have you seen the news lately?
It sucks.
Today's media landscape gives people
more ways than ever to hear only the
things they want to hear.
When confronted with ideas that
challenged their beliefs,
many react with outrage,
censorship and recently cries of fake
news.
This trend may seem to have popped out
of nowhere,
but this was actually predicted a long
time ago in a book you've probably read
Ray Bradbury's Fahrenheit 400.
Do you want in case you slept through
middle school English.
The book depicts a dark future,
or firemen have graduated from saving
cats.
The torching books in an attempt to
silence any troubling ideas Fahrenheit
is usually interpreted as an attack on
government censorship,
especially since Brad re wrote the book
in the midst of Mccarthy's war on
communism,
but there's actually someone else
Bradbury blames for the dystopia his
characters live in you.
Well not only you,
but all of us.
See in the book the main characters
informed that it was the public that
censored themselves.
It all started with the advent of mass
media technology advanced to such a
degree that people struggled to keep up
information,
rushed in from every direction,
overwhelming the population to quell
their anxiety.
People focused on smaller pieces of
information.
Beatty,
captain of the firefighters describes
this change,
how media has been reduced from
cumbersome novels to the gag.
The snap ending one column,
two sentences,
a headline than midair all vanishes just
like that we consume and forget and
consume.
Again,
rinse,
wash,
repeat the mind drinks less and less
soon.
People became addicts,
conditioned to feel pleasure from
frivolous content.
Anything thought provoking became
downright painful.
As a result,
people censored themselves from any
challenging ideas they sought to be
pacified,
numbed and validated soundbites,
factoids,
and vapid drama,
blurring out any troubling ideas blaring
out reality.
We see similar patterns with the rise of
social networking and the feed news
story after new story that generates as
you scroll video after video,
meme after meme,
directly fed and programs to your liking
just as long as you continue scrolling
in Fahrenheit,
the media concluded that it could
attract the biggest audience by routing
itself,
if anything controversial,
effectively ceding control of its
content to outrage our media.
Saturated society is an extension of
Bradbury's vision with so many different
channels,
streaming services and websites,
media has fragmented each appealing to
their own individual audiences.
Fox News for conservatives,
MSNBC for liberals and Youtube for flat
earthers get each of these media outlets
must pander to their audience,
which is why Fox News can't piss off
mainstream republicans,
evangelicals and NRA members and Msnbc
can't piss off mainstream Democrats,
progressives,
and gun control advocates.
The result is isolated bubbles that
become harder and harder to burst.
It's like beatty said,
offended as few as possible.
The truth is secondary to comfort,
and once someone finds their bubble,
don't label anything that challenges
their ideas
as fake news,
both in the book and in real life.
People protect themselves from anything
that confounds or upsets.
They just want to continue watching and
scrolling and watching and scrolling,
watching,
scrolling.
So what happens next in Fahrenheit?
It's here that the government steps in
encouraging everyone to stay in the
bubble and torch any stragglers.
Sometimes literally,
are we destined for a similar fate or
will the champions of free thought save
assault?
Alright,
hope you guys enjoyed that.
Let us know what you think in the
comments below and also if you want to
see a pretty close to final cut of our
next pilot coming out,
join us over@wisecrackplus.com.
It's our patrion page where we're always
uploading new cuts and stuff and asking
our patrons for feedback and it's a
great community,
so we'd love if you guys were a part of
it,
right?
It's because of all of you guys.
All of our patrons and our fans are able
to make all these really cool pilots and
work with some amazing artists and
animators and musicians,
so thanks so much.
Be sure to check out our pilots and
we'll catch it the next one.
Thanks guys.
Please.